Here's how I did it.
Looking at the markup for the page,
I can see that the search link
is actually higher in the DOM
order than the other links.
And it's using this pull-right class
here to float over to one side.
The easiest thing to do here is
to just move the search button
below the other elements.
That will give the same
visual presentation but
now the tab order makes sense.
I also noticed that
the newsletter is jumping
ahead of the other elements
on the page because it's
absolutely positioned to appear
at the bottom of the page.
Just like the search link,
I'll move the newsletter
down to the bottom of the document
just after the main element.
Now is also a good time to improve
our semantics a little bit.
Instead of just using a div for
this element,
I can replace it with a footer tag.
Doing so can benefit screen readers
who rely on these kind of landmarked
elements to navigate the page.
And it's also a little more concise
than saying div class equals footer.
I'll also talk more about semantics and
navigation in a future lesson.